Resident Evil 4 remake is finally out
and it is packed with Secrets here are
16 things that will make you feel almost
as cool as Leon S Kennedy pulling myself
out
[Music]
the knife is a big deal in Resident Evil
4 remake not only can Leon slash and
stab he can use it to deflect and Parry
certain attacks and projectiles getting
perfect parries can be tricky so we
recommend practicing that in the early
hours
all right
sorry must have slipped knives can also
help you escape grabs stealth kill foes
and finish off down enemies before they
turn just keep in mind that this and
deflecting will eventually cause your
knife to break fortunately Leon's combat
knife can be repaired and upgraded with
the merchant oh well that's good work if
I do say so myself you probably already
know that Leon can roundhouse kick
stunned enemies but did you know that
the sound of impact is different if his
kick is a finishing blow well kind of if
you hear this
instead of this then you just landed a
critical hit this can happen with almost
any weapon but when it comes to kicks it
means your foe isn't getting back up and
it happens fairly often
stop it
enemies in Resident Evil 4 react
appropriately depending on where you
shoot them shoot the legs and they'll
fall over the arms and they'll drop
their weapon of course if an enemy is
holding an explosive you can shoot that
and it will go boom
if you want to do the most damage then
aim for the head there are even some
guns like the rifle that have bullet
penetration these Firearms can take out
multiple enemies with a single bullet
the ganados love their bear traps they
are everywhere in the early hours of
Resident Evil 4 remake and that's
because the gennados will actively place
them before and during combat
fortunately you can also lead them right
into their own traps come on
gonados aren't the only thing you'll be
shooting in Resident Evil 4 remake like
the original small Wildlife like crows
snakes and fish can be killed for
resources crows typically drop gunpowder
or cash while fishing snakes can be
consumed for health additionally you'll
find chickens pigs and cows wandering
the world chickens will occasionally
Drop Eggs which can be either thrown or
eaten
meanwhile cows and pigs can and will
fight back if you or an enemy disturbs
them
yourself
there are a ton of weapons in Resident
Evil 4 remake and almost all of them can
be upgraded this is great for folks who
plan on playing through the game
multiple times but if you're a one and
done kind of gamer then I recommend
picking three or four weapons to invest
your hard-earned cash into in order to
fully upgrade a weapon and unlock its
bonus perk it can cost hundreds of
thousands of pacetas and if you
diversify Your Arsenal too much your
guns might be underpowered this is
especially important on harder
difficulties fortunately you can sell
back weapons for 90 to 95 percent of the
cost so don't be afraid to try out
different guns the only caveat is that
you should only purchase the exclusive
upgrade perk for a gun if you plan on
keeping it
the rocket launcher is a powerful
one-time use tool in Resident Evil 4. it
may be expensive but it can One-Shot any
enemy including bosses if you're under
prepared or in a hurry just use a rocket
launcher I'd recommend saving it for a
later boss but it's up to you not my
place to say really but sometimes things
are more interesting if you keep a Level
Playing Field don't you fight wait
before you sell that fancy gemstone and
lay it into a treasure throughout re4
you'll find plenty of treasures with
gemstone Slots make sure to fill every
gemstone slot within a treasure in order
to get the highest selling price you can
even get bonuses by mixing and matching
different gemstones if you really want
to maximize your profits then you might
want to save all your yellow diamonds to
get the same color bonus for a huge
profit fans of the original Resident
Evil 4 already know this but flash
grenades do a lot more than stun enemies
if you toss a flash grenade with any
exposed parasites around it will
instantly kill them I highly recommend
purchasing the flash grenade blueprint
from Fortune as soon as you can and
keeping a few of these in your back
pocket just in case
[Applause]
did you know that if you shoot the Bell
on top of the church you can skip the
entire opening fight scene it's tough to
do without a scoped weapon so we
recommend saving this for a second
playthrough this little trick was
discovered by Sora keshu and tactical
banter over on Reddit
La Campana
throughout your adventure you will come
across shooting galleries here you can
earn tokens by completing specific
challenges these tokens can be used to
unlock perk charms that can be equipped
to Leon's attache case these Charms have
a wide range of effects both in and out
of combat so be sure to read the
description carefully keep in mind that
you can't double up on charms so you can
sell any extras to the merchant
technically Resident Evil 4 has two
kinds of in-game currency pacetas and
spinels spinels can be acquired by
completing requests and then traded to
the merchant for specific items complete
as many requests as you can because
spinels can get you all sorts of useful
items and weapons you can even purchase
weapon upgrade tickets that will unlock
a weapons exclusive perk just know that
you won't get enough spindles in one
playthrough to purchase everything
treasure maps can be purchased with
spinels and these Mark a bunch of
treasure on your map whenever you get to
a new location get the treasure map
right away to ensure you don't miss any
valuable items if you don't have enough
spinels for a treasurement you can still
hear the treasure as it usually creaks
when you're near it
foreign
just shoot these bird cage looking
things when you see one and collect
whatever's inside there's a fair bit of
backtracking throughout Resident Evil
4's story and even more if you want to
collect all the treasure and complete
all the requests previously explored
areas can repopulate with enemies so
beyond the lookout certain areas will
eventually get closed off too so make
sure to backtrack whenever you can if
you destroy all 16 Clockwork cast stands
you will unlock a special weapon I won't
spoil it here but it's definitely worth
the effort to find them listen for a
wind-up sound when you see one just
shoot it
now this is a bit of a weird one but the
explosive bolts can be used before
triggering certain cutscenes for an
interesting effect for example if you
fire a bolt near the switch before you
trigger the cutscene you will kill this
guy before he can set off the ambush
keep in mind that this borders on a
glitch so it may be patched out in
future updates there are 16 tips that
will hopefully make you feel almost as
cool as Leon S Kennedy make sure to
subscribe to Gamespot for more Resident
Evil 4.